[Applause]
Comic Con 2018 is in full swing and he
teamed up with the multiplayer golf app
golf class by play demek it's a little
green fun I need a picture
I'm here with ash crossing and let's be
real ash no one knows epic battles more
than our favorite superheroes right
we're debating who might win at the
ultimate golf game DC burst Marvel I
mean come on go I'm diggin marble-sized
because you know have you seen Thor's
muscles the god of thunder would have a
hammer of a swing
all right true but let's talk about
Batman who would hands-down have the
best Caddy with Alfred I mean holy
holding a1 Batman okay nice plan there
but I don't think anyone can dominate
the green like the whole I see what you
do there okay but we also have the flash
would at least keep the game moving
there's that cheater and Golf is a
marathon not a sprint
if you will all right all right not sure
why we're even debating it when you know
Wonder Woman would dominate and keep
everyone honest but we're not gonna
settle this here
I think I can beat that we found the
trees
[Applause]
yeah
queen of the butter
there
[Applause]
in a video game guys is the
award-winning golf duel at perfect for
short matches but friends and family
[Applause]
[Music]